es una de las mayores medidas de
estímulo en la historia de eeuu y ha
sido aclamada por algunos como una nueva
guerra contra la pobreza y recibirán
cheques de 1400 dólares para finales de
marzo donde a ver que la mitad de los
niños estadounidenses que viven en
pobreza no lo estarán debido a este
proyecto de ley of despair que ayuda
está en camino
además de los cheques de estímulo de
1400 dólares que brindan un alivio
inmediato a millones de estadounidenses
el proyecto de ley incluye varias
medidas destinadas a beneficiar a los
más pobres extenderá los beneficios
federales por desempleo ampliará los
subsidios de atención médica y los
cupones de alimentos y proporcionará
apoyo financiero para varios programas
estatales de bienestar otra disposición
importante tiene por objeto convertir un
crédito fiscal parental existente en un
subsidio para hijos proporcionando un
ingreso garantizado para las familias
con niños en las calles de nueva york
los residentes acogieron con
satisfacción el plan sin embargo algunos
cuestionan si están haciendo lo
suficiente para abordar la pobreza a
largo plazo deben beneficiar a un poco
pero creo que hay que hacer más creo que
deberíamos recibir un pago mensual que
ayudará mucho a mejorar la economía
porque la gente todavía está aquí sin
trabajos y sin ayuda por desempleo los
estudios estiman que el plan de rescate
estadounidense podría reducir la pobreza
en un tercio y la pobreza infantil a la
mitad en 2021 sacando a millones de la
escasez sin embargo con la mayoría de
las disposiciones del proyecto de ley de
un solo uso o que expiran en un año
muchos están pidiendo a la
administración que introduzca medidas
más permanentes